françois legault bonsoir bonjour
messieurs legault on est dans le dernier
droit
vous êtes déstabilisé par tous est
question d'immigration franchement il ya
une question tout le monde se pose
comment se fait-il que vous soyez pas
capable de répondre à des questions de
base dans un dossier qui est quand même
centrale à votre campagne électorale
écoutez d'abord nos objectifs sont
clairs ce qu'on disait qu'on veut
réduire de 50 milles à 40 mille le
nombre d'immigrants pour mieux s'en
occuper ce qu'on dit aussi c'est qu'on
veut que les nouveaux arrivants
réussissent un test de français pointe
est de valeur avant de recevoir le
certificat de sélection maintenant de
dix bons actuellement il ya différentes
étapes ou fédérale avec la résidence
permanente la citoyenneté
il ya des tests de connaissance du
canada y des tests d'anglais et de
français
bon une mécanique mais ce qui est
important c'est de comprendre c'est quoi
l'objectif
oui mais si vous lui proposez de
renégocier au fond cette entente avec
avec ottawa
guy vous la maîtrise est pas il ya quand
même quelque chose d'un peu inquiétant
pour les gens n'ont d'abord à court
terme on veut pas rien négocié katawal
ce qu'on dit c'est l'immigration
économique qui est sélectionné par le
gouvernement du québec
donc le certificat de sélection est
donné par le gouvernement du québec
on veut à l'avenir qu'il ya des
conditions avant que le gouvernement du
québec donne un certificat de sélection
donc on n'est pas en train de parler
lors de
comme le dit monsieur couillard en
faisant peur au monde d'expulsion on
parle de donner ou non ainsi que deux
sélections avec son récent qu'est ce qui
va arriver à ce qu'ils passent pas le
test de français tous aveugles ou encore
répondu vraiment assistant d'écouté
dans le fond c'est comme ça se passe à
peu près partout quand on réussit pas
les tests mais on n'est pas admis son
n'est pas ni baisse comme un travail
avec un permis temporaire il le permis
est échue donc la personne se retrouve
sans statut légal appelez ça comme vous
voulez mais ce qui est important dire
c'est que nous le gouvernement du québec
on va donner un certificat de sélection
une fois que l'immigrant ont réussi un
test de francs
un c est un test de valeur sinon donne
pas satisfait donc c'est que c'est pas
si compliqué que ça
mais sur ça c'est votre proposition et
sur des choses de base de cette entente
qui existe avec ottawa il ya plein de
choses que vous savez pas est-ce que
vous reconnaissez quand même que c'est
un peu ça peut être un peu dérangeant
pour les gens ou étonnant à toi
écoutez effectivement je pense pour que
la majorité des québécois sachent à quel
moment il ya un test de français ou
d'anglais
combien de points ça donne le test de
français ou d'anglais on sait sur les
plus simples que ça monsieur lost et
monica sion si spécifiquement ce que ça
prend pour obtenir sa citoyenneté comme
éteint faut passer au canada c'est quand
même des choses de sorte qu'on disait
avant d'avoir sa citoyenneté il ya des
enquêtes de sécurité mais faut aussi
avoir sa résidence permanente dans
certains cas pas toujours depuis trois
ans je pense que les québécois
comprennent bien que ce qui est
important c'est de dire avec un
gouvernement du québec à la venue
d'abord combien va en avoir dix migrants
parce qu'actuellement on en perd 26 %
les migrants qui quittent le québec dans
les dix premières années donc ses 13000
sur cinquante mille donc si on arrive à
bien intégrer car en mai au total on
n'en voit plus en emploi que la
situation actuelle c'est important de
nouveaux chiffres ou qui sont pas tout à
fait cela mais c'est pas une guerre de
chiffres que je veux faire avec vous
mais disons que vous voulez baisser les
seuils d'immigration l'immigration c'est
intimement lié on le voit en ce moment
au québec avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qu'est ce que vous comptez
faire pour régler ce problème là parce
que là nous on arrive de beauce tout le
monde nous parle de sel tout le monde a
besoin de travailleurs et on en a pas
assez
plusieurs shows d'abord le problème ou
le défi économique le plus important au
québec les québécois qui nous écoutent
ce soir ce qu'ils nous disent et les
salaires au québec en moyenne sont
beaucoup plus bas qu'en ontario dans le
reste du canada
donc faut avoir plus d'équipements dans
les entreprises plus d'intelligence
artificielle plus de valeur ajoutée
donc faut augmenter sa laque même
impliqué de la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
l'immigration on n'a pas réussi ce coup
hier les libéraux sont depuis 15 ans
on perd 26 % des immigrants puis le taux
de chômage après 5,1 et 14,1 pour cent
donc il ya un problème là mais c'est
maintenant qu'on en a besoin les
entrepreneurs à qui on parle et qui
disent on est obligé de fermer certains
jours de la semaine
on perd des contrats parce qu'on manque
de mazzé maintenant c'est parce que vous
faites court terme il attendait de la
beauce les libéraux depuis 15 ans ont à
peu près pas réussi à ce que des
immigrants choisissent d'aller vivre en
région
donc c'est un échec le fait qu'on a à
perdre 26 pour cinq quitte pour une
autre province
c'est pour deux raisons essentiellement
trouvent pas d'emploi parce que mauvaise
reconnaissance des diplômes mauvaise
reconnaissance des acquis 58 % des
immigrants l'année dernière ne parlait
pas français c'est de se trouver un
emploi quand on a vu ici qu'on parle pas
français
donc il ya des changements à faire à
notre modèle des migrations
mais qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
entrepreneurs qui sont pris en ce moment
et qui disent il faut pas baisser les
seuils d'immigration on en a besoin il
ya un maire de meaux ce qui disait c'est
pas une bonne idée c'est pas la solution
les gens payent pour aller chercher des
travailleurs à l'étranger eux mêmes ce
que je vous dis le cycle actuellement
des libéraux en accepte 50000 par année
puis en reste trente sept mille nouveaux
n'accepter 40000 en fonction des besoins
des entreprises de chacune des régions
du québec
ça va être mieux pour les immigrants ça
va être mieux pour les entreprises vont
avoir toutes proportions gardées - à
montréal plus dans les régions où il ya
des entreprises qui cherchent des mains
de mais aussi faut augmenter les emplois
mieux payés au québec on a beaucoup
d'emplois 12,15 dollars dollars on n'a
pas assez d'emploi 30 40 $ de l'heure
c'est pour ça qu'on soit de la
péréquation ce pour se prendre les moins
riches que l'ontario l'écart de richesse
du québec avec l'ontario opp a bougé
depuis 15 ans donc les libéraux ont pas
réussi à attirer des investissements
privés à créer des emplois mieux payés
si on va attirer des immigrants
il faut savoir des emplois de qualité à
offrir en impro
blême de qualité d'emploi au québec là
vous il ya toute cette question
d'immigration mais pas seulement soit
dans le débat on vous a vu beaucoup
d'analystes audio il a quand même
l'image d'un chef de l'opposition disons
encore comment comment vous allez
démontrer aux québécois que vous êtes
vous avez les toffes d'un premier
ministre aujourd'hui encore vous poser
une question sur le nouveau brunswick
comme province bilingue au canada
si vous aviez vous saviez pas vous
n'avez pas la réponse à l'ipod comment
vous allez démontrer s'il n'y a pas eu
de débat france nouveau prendre nous et
c'est malheureux parce qu'effectivement
c'est une province bilingue mais je
reviens d'abord à l'équipe 1 g quand les
gens parlent de moncade financier le
trésorier de la banque nationale et à
nos candidats
le premier vice président d'img la
caisse de dépôt et aux candidats
on a malgré de blé pour s'occuper des
aînés onu jean françois robert jeunes
enseignants extraordinaire qui croient
comme moins ça prend la maternelle 4 1
comme en ontario pour augmenter nos taux
de diplomation vanille chronique à la
santé pour bien gérer parce que le
docteur barrette tout centraliser les
gens ont pas de médecin de famille qui
est disponible quand ils sont malades
dont sont obligés d'aller engorgé
urgence donc faux j'ai changé la gestion
du réseau de la santé
moi je pense j'ai une équipe formidable
de gestionnaires de jean d'économie de
jean d'éducation
ce sont les préoccupations des gens
c'est pas vrai que la question de lui on
doit être seulement au taux de
l'immigration les gens ont des
préoccupations en éducation en santé
trouve qu'ils ont pas beaucoup d'argent
au portefeuille nous on propose 2400 $
par enfant une nouvelle allocation
familiale jusqu'à l'âge de 17 ans
monsieur couleurs propose pas ça alors
on va vous souhaiter une bonne fin de
campagne monsieur legault merci beaucoup
moins belle peau
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]